[Music]
i'm lauren zima at the race to erase ms
gala at the Beverly Hilton where
bachelor Nick vile finally broke his
silence on a major bachelor story
everything that's gone down with his
friend Chris soules have you spoken to
him at all and what was your reaction I
mean without no contact with Chris my
action was obviously the same as
everyone else that it's a terrible
tragedy and you know more than anything
I'm just praying for the the gentleman
who passed away and their family and
just wishing for the best for everyone
involved well I mean we reached out and
just not heard from them I've kind of
let that things be I mean it's kind of a
surreal thing right now and I think it's
best for everyone just kind of you know
just pray for the people involved and
you know that's all they can really do
that's going to be beneficial at this
point is this a moment for a bachelor
nation to kind of come together a little
bit I mean you guys are all such good
friends with each other
um I mean I you know everything
everyone's as supportive they get they
can be - Chris but you know it's a
terrible situation
you